NTSB investigators
are back
at a Boeing production
plant in their effort
to determine why
a door plug blew off a Boeing 73
max nine jet mid-flight earlier
this month.
The investigators are now trying
to build a timeline of the incid
We have CNN aviation
correspondent Pete Mountain.
Joining us now on this story.
You've been on it
from the beginning here.
What's the latest on the investi
Well,
this is the first of many visits
by the NTSB to Boeing.
And remember
that the FAA is also
doing its own investigation
as it ordered
this grounding of the 737 max ni
which remains in place,
Just spoke
with the head of the FAA
in a one on one interview,
and he says
his inspectors are on site at Bo
with a focus on quality control.
FAA administrator
Mike Whitaker told me
the max nine
door plugged design is a good de
but only when it's properly exec
That's a big caveat.
The bolts that hold the door
plug on the plane are key.
There were four of them.
And if they are not installed,
then the door can shimmy
out of its retaining grooves
and shoot off with explosive for
like we saw back on January
5th on Alaska 1282.
Here is FAA administrator Mike W
The design, when it's properly
executed, is a sound, safe
airworthy design.
Our focus has been on production
So where we are looking
now is quality assurance,
quality control at Boeing.
We've got inspectors on site
overseeing production,
examining the actual aircraft
coming off the line
to ensure
everything is where it ought to
The FAA
now has a sampling of data
from about a quarter of the max
in the U.S..
It's looking at measurements to
what airlines will need
to inspect in order
to ground these planes.
I also asked the FAA chief
if the flying public
should be afraid of the 737 max
And he told me
the FAA is not going
to let this plane back in the ai
until they're convinced
this issue is taken care of.
And Boeing's CEO
will be meeting with lawmakers
and they're pretty frustrated.
Yeah,
and some of the meetings are tak
right now.
Boeing CEO
Dave Calhoun
on Capitol Hill right now
as Boeing is announcing
this daylong safety stand down t
We know he's going to meet
with Senator Maria Cantwell toda
She is one of the top Democrats
who oversees the committee
that oversees aviation.
And she says
that even after these closed
door hearings,
she would like to see potentiall
some hearings and Boeing
being held to account in public
So we'll see.
Boeing got lucky here
that that happened
when everyone was seated
at the altitude that it happened
We have to remember that.
Pete,
thank you so much
for following this throughout. B
Let's discuss this further
with Miles O'Brien.
He's a CNN aviation
analyst, pilot and science
correspondent for PBS NewsHour.
Miles, thank you so much for joi
Great to see you.
If you were asking questions
of these folks over at Boeing,
what would you want answered?
I'd like to know about their pro
You know,
one of the things that
happens in the case
of trying to get all these airpl
the door is as the subassemblies
there,
they might be put together
in this case with the door plug
But is it possible that the work
to make it easier to work on the
took that door plug out
and then didn't really have
an official procedure
for putting it back in?
And as a result, some things wer
Those kinds of little details
are really important
in aviation, in theory.
Boris,
you should be able to trace
a piece of paper
to every piece on that airplane.
And that paper trail
should lead to individuals
to what they did or didn't do.
And if they did, in fact,
take that door, plug out unoffic
you don't have that paper trail.
So things like that
are very important in aviation.
That's some really fascinating
perspective.
FAA inspectors say that they are
increasing the level of scrutiny
of that production process
that you're describing.
What does it look like
when the FAA steps in
and does that sort of thing?
Well, it
makes me wonder why
we don't have the FAA there
more often and in greater number
It is a matter of money.
And this is an important questio
for Congress to address.
Essentially, the airlines are a
They're the builders of these ai
use their own people to do inspe
Now, you know,
you clearly
there is a potential conflict
of interest there.
Now, in the interest of aviation
the manufacturers would tell you
that it's safe
because no one wants to put an u
aircraft in the air.
But there are subtle ways
that that things can be overlook
like bolts that need to be tight
So should the FAA step up its on
inspection campaign
and not just be sending the troo
after you have had an incident
which could have caused
a much greater calamity?
And, Miles,
Boeing obviously not only facing
from federal inspectors and lawm
but its airline partners to
a lot of money is being lost
because these planes are grounde
What do you anticipate
the long term impact of
this is going to be
for Boeing's business?
I think it's hard to
overstate it
when you have the CEO of United
saying, you know,
I may not purchase
the Max ten, the next version of
You know,
Boeing
Borris was the gold
standard for the world.
And subsequent
to its merger with McDonnell
Douglas in 1997,
the corporate culture changed.
A lot of I subcontracting came i
a lot of outsourcing, a lot of c
of nonunion jobs at other locati
Their whole philosophy changed
after that merger.
And a lot of people would tell y
that is the root of the problem
that there's been a fundamental
corporate culture change,
and that means change at the top
Really interesting insight.
Miles O'Brien,
thanks so much for the update.
You're welcome, Boris.